2020 has been a terrifying year - to say the
least - but that doesn't mean horror fans
aren't clamoring for some more enjoyable scares
in the near future.
Well, they're in luck.
From high-impact sequels to chilling originals,
these are the creepiest movies due for release
in 2021.
Directed by Nia DaCosta and co-written by
horror legend Jordan Peele, Candyman is a
sequel to the original 1992 horror classic
- one that picks up in real time, decades
after the events of the first movie.
The film follows multimedia artist Anthony
McCoy, whose obsession with the now fully
gentrified site of the infamous Candyman murders
begins to take on an entire life of its own.
The new Candyman trailer offers up a whole
lot of hints about what might go down in the
movie, including a number of callbacks to
the original, such as the presence of an overwhelming
number of bees and the iconic imagery of Candyman
himself.
However, the movie looks like it's diverging
from the original by suggesting that Anthony
might actually be getting possessed by the
spirit of Candyman, as opposed to simply being
haunted by him, taking things to an entirely
new level of scary.
And yeah, Tony Todd, who played the original
bee-loving slasher, is returning to the franchise,
too.
Candyman is set for release in August 2021.
The Office alum John Krasinski made a surprising
pivot from comedy to horror with 2018's A
Quiet Place, a surprising box office smash
that was both written and directed by the
comedian-turned-filmmaker.
Set in an apocalyptic world overrun by human-eating
monsters who respond to sound, the Abbott
family has finally figured out how to make
their life work.
That is, until a series of tragedies unfold,
including the loss of a loved one and a chilling
ending in which a postpartum Evelyn and her
surviving family members must face off with
a steadily-growing horde of monsters.
While details about A Quiet Place Part II
are sparse, the teasers hint that the remaining
Abbotts will have to leave their farmhouse
sanctuary and venture out into a hostile world
- one filled not only flesh-eating monsters,
but also other survivors.
A Quiet Place Part II will feature the same
original cast, including John Krasinski in
flashbacks, as well as adding Cillian Murphy
and Djimon Hounsou to the ensemble.
The tentative release date is set for April
2021.
"Let the game begin."
The Saw franchise has seen its fair share
of ups and downs over the years.
Sure, each of the eight installments has more
than provided on the gore front, but as for
quality - well, that's been a little inconsistent.
Fortunately, 2017's Jigsaw put some new twists
and turns into what had become a rather stale
plot.
Presumably following in Jigsaw's vein, May
2021 will see the release of Spiral: From
the Book of Saw, starring Chris Rock as Detective
Zeke Banks, whose current investigation will
lead all the way back to the first movie in
the Saw saga.
But Chris Rock isn't just starring in his
first ever horror movie - he's actually a
long-time Saw fan and the one who came up
with Spiral's concept, and wrote the story's
treatment.
Longtime Saw collaborators are all on board
the Jigsaw train for Spiral as well, with
Darren Lynn Bousman directing and both James
Wan and Leigh Whannell signed on as producers.
The newest installment of the Conjuring franchise,
The Devil Made Me Do It, will be the eighth
film set in that universe - although it's
actually a direct sequel to the first two
Conjuring movies.
Featuring Vera Farmiga and Patrick Wilson
as paranormal investigators Ed and Lorraine
Warren, The Devil Made Me Do It follows the
infamous real-life 1981 Arne Cheyenne Johnson
murder trial, which was the first time in
American legal history that demonic possession
was used as a "not guilty" defense.
Johnson's defense was laughed out of court,
but he served only five years of his 20-year sentence.
It's likely that the third proper Conjuring
movie will be suitably dramatic - with plenty
of nail-biting court scenes to break up all
those jump scares.
The Devil Made Me Do It is directed by The
Curse of La Llorona's Michael Chaves, and
Conjuring franchise "founder" James Wan has
signed on as producer.
The Devil Made Me Do It should hit cinemas
and video-on-demand services in June 2021.
Having first been introduced to the world
of Marvel comics all the way back in 1971,
Morbius the Living Vampire is finally getting
his own movie.
2021's Morbius tells the story of Michael
Morbius, a human turned bloodsucker thanks
to the side effects of a cure for his rare
blood disease.
But while Morbius might be a vamp, he has
none of the qualities you've come to expect
from the supernatural species - other than
super strength and an extreme lust for blood.
Also starring Doctor Who alum Matt Smith,
as well as Jared Harris, Morbius will be part
of Sony's ever-expanding Spiderverse.
From the trailer, Morbius looks suitably brooding,
gothic, and action-packed.
It's also set to bring some disturbingly brilliant
creature effects to the table, as well as
a cameo or two - specifically, Michael Keaton
is reprising his role as Adrian Toomes from
Spider-Man: Homecoming.
This superhero horror crossover should be
hitting theaters in March 2021.
Fede Alvarez's chilling 2016 horror feature,
Don't Breathe, has had a sequel in the works
ever since it first came out.
The first Don't Breathe followed Norman Nordstrom,
a blind veteran who's rumored to live with
loads of cash stashed around his house.
After three robbers break in and try to steal
from him, Nordstrom reveals himself to be
far more capable than his reclusive reputation
might suggest, brutalizing the robbers one
by one as they attempt to escape his home.
Eventually, Rocky, one of the robbers, manages
to escape, and Don't Breathe ends with Nordstrom
surviving to plan his revenge.
But things seem to have taken a turn in Don't
Breathe 2.
Apparently, Nordstrom has moved to a remote
cabin in the woods, where he now cares for
an orphan girl - a kind of replacement for
the daughter he lost before the events of
the original movie.
Eventually, people from her past track her
down, not realizing who her new adopted father is.
The big question, of course, is whether Rocky
will appear in this sequel.
But there's no news on those plot details
yet.
What you certainly can expect, though, is
that Nordstrom will pull out all his incredible
tactical skills to protect his surrogate daughter,
just like he did in the original.
Don't Breathe 2 is set for an August 2021
release.
In what will be the fifth and final installment
of James DeMonaco's Purge franchise, The Forever
Purge is one of the upcoming 2021 releases
that we know the least about.
No teaser trailer has been released, and plot
details have been scarce, other than DeMonaco
telling Entertainment Weekly that he had come
up with a "really cool" way to round out the
last of his ultraviolent, socially-aware horror
series.
Set in an America that allows a 12-hour window
once a year where all crimes are legal, each
installment of The Purge franchise has deepened
its cultural critique regarding the roots
of violence, state-sanctioned crime, and social
control through fear.
While some installments of the franchise have
hinted at changes in legislation to end the
Purge in this fictional America, the title
of the final film suggests that an end to
this horrific event might not actually be
on the horizon.
The Forever Purge is slated for a July 2021
theatrical release, followed quickly by a
video-on-demand release.
Adam Robitel's 2019 movie Escape Room capitalized
on the new entertainment trend of, you guessed
it, escape rooms.
Also known as puzzle rooms, these are those
stylized locked rooms in which participants
must solve clues to find their way out.
However, in the movie itself, the titular
room turns out to not be a game at all, but
rather a twisted experiment to see who's the
fittest in a group of already-traumatized
survivors.
The whole affair is orchestrated by an enigmatic
figure named the Puzzlemaker, and by the end
of the film, the two survivors begin spying
on the escape room organizers, waiting for
their moment of revenge.
Escape Room 2 stars both survivors as leads
once again, suggesting the sequel will pick
up where the first left off.
Orphan actress Isabelle Fuhrman will also
join the Escape Room 2 cast, along with Pose
star Indya Moore.
There's no release date announced yet, other
than that it will be released in the later
half of 2021.
Expect scores of fiendishly clever traps,
a bunch of cleverly designed rooms, and some
very disturbing kills.
While Oren Peli's Paranormal Activity series
has been one of the most lucrative horror
franchises of all time, raking in piles of
cash thanks to its low-budget filmmaking,
the critical reception towards the films themselves
has been fairly inconsistent.
With Peli's bump to producer after the first
film and Christopher Landon taking over writing
- and eventually directing — most of the
subsequent movies, Paranormal Activity has
followed the Featherstone family's demonic
curse as it reaches out into the lives of
the people who have met them.
Details about the seventh installment - including
its subtitle, cast, and plot - remain a mystery
at the moment, but the film is still planned
for a 2021 release.
But what we do know is that Landon will be
returning to the project in some capacity,
although he's confirmed he won't be involved
in the script or production, as he had been
in previous installments.
Run Sweetheart Run is based on a terrifying
real-life encounter that began with a sexual
assault and ended with director Shana Feste
barefoot in the Hollywood Hills, with no phone
or wallet, and forced to walk to her home
in West Hollywood.
Ella Balinska stars as the titular "sweetheart,"
across from Game of Thrones star actor Pilou
Asbek as her date-turned-stalker in the urban
landscape of Los Angeles.
"I think every woman could relate to something
like that, because every woman has their own
real-life horror film to tell."
Inspired by the social justice style of horror
put to use in Jordan Peele's Get Out, Feste
wanted to draw attention to the daily misogyny
that women deal with - and take it to its
most devastating extreme.
In that sense, Run Sweetheart Run is the true
story of most women's ultimate nightmare,
and although it's not going to be an easy
watch, it might just be the sleeper horror
hit of the year.
Run Sweetheart Run also features Sense8's
Aml Ameen and Marvel's own Clark Gregg.
The film premiered at Sundance to an excellent
critical reception in 2019, and will be hitting
Amazon Prime in early 2021.
After the surprising success of the 2018 sequel
to the '70s classic slasher Halloween, horror
fans were thrilled at the news there was a
full Halloween sequel trilogy in the works,
one which will explore the long-term trauma
suffered by Laurie Strode and her family at
the hands of serial killer-stalker Michael
Myers.
Picking up exactly where the 2018 Halloween
left off, Halloween Kills finds the Strode
women newly traumatized by a deeply disturbing
encounter with the Shape; one that results
in more than double the original body count
of Halloween.
Featuring Judy Greer as Laurie's daughter
Karen and Andi Matichak as her granddaughter
Allyson, Halloween Kills will also focus a
good chunk of its story on the many denizens
of Haddonfield who've also been living in
the shadow of Myers' rampages.
These include Laurie's original babysitting
charges Tommy Doyle, now a grown man played
by Anthony Michael Hall, and his friend, Lindsey
Wallace, played by the original movie's Kyle
Richards.
So, where 2018's Halloween explored the trauma
of the Strode women, Halloween Kills looks
to examine the collective trauma of the town
- as Myers embarks on yet another rampage.
Originally slated for an October 14th 2020
release, the new premiere is scheduled for
October 15th, 2021.
A follow-up, Halloween Ends, is due for release
in October 2022.
"Goodbye, Michael."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.